all right school is back in session and
silver state equality is launching their
lgbtq plus student advisory council for
high school students here to tell us
more is andre wade with silver state
equality welcome my friend thank you for
having me good to see you yes i'm here
so tell us more about the program so we
thought about this student advisory
council as a way to engage students in
the process for civic engagement for
them to identify issues that are
happening in school to hopefully enhance
school climate for them but then also
address some of the
social isolation that they've had
working in a virtual environment staying
at home for so long and so we're open to
have them engaged and participate in
something fun and interesting to make a
change was that kind of how the program
launched coming out of the pandemic when
so many people were isolated from
friends and and other students that how
kind of the whole program launched yes
absolutely so our board of advisors were
concerned about the students um and the
issues that they were going through and
we had heard unfortunately about some of
the suicide attempts of students and we
wanted to make sure that we had a way
that we addressed it in a way that was
engaging for the students so this was
born out of that back in 2020. and some
of the stats too the suicide numbers i
was reading some of the stats you sent
over are so much more higher and also
the homeless numbers are much higher as
well yeah so the rate for homeless youth
is said to be up to 40 percent
identifies lgbtq plus and then recently
there was a number that was stated about
a national suicide prevention hotline
where 50 of the call-ins were from
people who identified as lgbtq plus so
that's staggering numbers we're here to
help out and we hope that we can have
the support of the community well las
vegas we're supportive community people
watching right now how can students get
involved how can teachers get involved
how can parents get involved so they can
contact us they can go to our website at
silverstateequality.org
they can contact me directly andre at
silverstateequality.org
we're going to soon have information on
our website they can apply ask us
questions and hopefully get things
moving before school starts it's a great
thing you're doing how does the
application process work or how do you
guys select the students for the council
so we want students to apply if they are
under the age of 18 we want their
parents permission parents are welcome
to speak with us to get a sense of the
program we're going to have mentors
involved as well they're going to go
through a background check
orientation and so the council is going
to be primarily students so up to 20
people we want 51 at least students and
then the mentors to be there to guide
the students in the process do you guys
need more mentors by the way are you
looking for mentors that's something
people watching that can reach out and
help out with that absolutely if people
have a background in education if
they're civically engaged if they um
just want to help and provide their
expertise maybe they're from the
hospitality industry
they have a funnel for students who want
to get into the hospitality industry
then sure they definitely can reach out
to us and apply i love it andre what's
the website people want to get involved
in it is silverstateequality.org
thank you i love the fact that you gave
out your personal email to help people
out as well thank you so much andre
jillian we'll send it over